Hi, my name is John of
John Bear Woodworks,
located in Windber, Pennsylvania.
I restore antiques and furniture.
Today, I am restoring this
three-mirror 1950s vanity.
Since I knew that this piece
had been painted over with
several coats of paint,
I was just really excited
to see what was hidden under there.
I start by applying a gel stripper,
and I apply that with a brush.
And I like to really glob it on.
You've got to get it on thick
and then let it sit.
It can't be dry.
It has to stay wet, so it's working.
And then, once you let that
sit for 15, 20 minutes,
you can really start
scraping and finding out
what you have hiding
underneath your projects.
I like to use just this regular
run-of-the-mill putty knife.
I round the edges on it a little bit
so it won't have any sharp edges
that will gouge the furniture,
and always just take special care,
use light pressure,
not to gouge, scratch it any more.
As those chemicals in the stripper
sit on top of that finish,
whatever you're stripping,
it just liquefies that finish,
and it leaves you with this sludge.
I typically scrape it
right into a metal old paint can.
A tip I got one time
from an old-timer I used to work with
is this sawdust trick.
When I apply the sawdust,
it soaks up all that stripper,
and you're not left with
all that gooey mess on there
that you need to wipe off or anything.
As I'm using this technique,
you want to make sure that
you go with the grain,
just like you would with sanding
or scraping or anything.
You don't want to go against that grain.
Light pressure. You don't want to cause
any scratches or gouges to the wood.
I'm sanding to remove any
of the remaining residue
or the scratches that
might be in that wood.
And you'll really know
if there is anything left
when you go to apply the stain.
I usually start sanding
most any type of wood
with a 150, it's a pretty common grit,
and then I finish it up with a 220 grit.
And this will help to remove
any more of the scratches
that might have been in the wood
and make it really smooth,
especially, like, any type of maple
or really dense wood
is more likely to hold scratches.
Next, I will just use an iron
and a wet rag on the wood's surface
to remove any of the scratches or dings.
I will just move on to
some final odds and ends
and steps that I take to
just do some final touch-ups,
removing the scratches,
removing any of the last
finish that might be remaining,
before I do that one last
final sanding before staining.
I will use an oil-based stain,
that I mix this color to my preference.
And I like this reddish tint.
I feel like it really brings out
that bird's eye maple a lot more.
I typically will tell people
when I'm working on a piece
the red mahogany tends to look
a little bit more elegant or refined.
Once the stain has had a chance to set up
and dry for a couple days,
I apply the seal coat of
lacquer before I sand that
and apply the final topcoat.
It's always nice to see these pieces
come back to life for a second life
instead of ending up in the dump
or out to a curbside.
And I just really enjoy this work,
and it brings me happiness,
and it's good to see that
it makes other people happy.
He's my handy helper.